коричневий використовувати вечерю
дочка приносить
[Музика]
північні церкви домінують перед хатою
жук так мендес використовує втомленого
весною дівчата переїжджають додому
співайте, чого очікують від вас ваші матері
вечірній замок один, щоб почути епізод
хороше з найдурніших йде спалахи, що
вечерю дочка приносить вам сюди
не глухне колесо і радує солов'я
ваблять
але потім мати лежить перед хатою
малі знову сплять і йдуть
на світ тихий скрізь цвірінькання
тільки за старим звичаєм дівчата і в
соловейко
[Оплески]
[Музика]
12.30 вечора
Китай хоче Schumi Catania calcio nora
у той час для мене не було роботи
katja dieckow місто таке lovato
[Музика]